[Music]
on this sunday night
the worsting situation in canada's kovid
19
hot spots the crisis in alberta
there's lots of metrics in alberta that
are headed in the wrong direction
but there's a battle over tougher
restrictions the pandemic forecast in
quebec
the worst months of the pandemic
may actually be in front of us the
winter of our covet discontent
plus the pandemic and property while
real estate
is hot and the asteroid mission to space
and back
in six years
[Music]
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us it's been weeks since canada's
hardest hit provinces tightened up
measures to try to curb the spread of
cova-19
but the virus is still running rampant
take a look at the rate of infection
over the last seven days across the
country
alberta shows the biggest concern its
rate is more than twice as high as
quebec
and over three times higher than ontario
today
alberta once again recorded over 1800
new cases
as abigail beeman reports there are
calls for stricter measures but some
albertans are protesting the ones
already in place
this probably won't be the only virtual
christmas performance you watch in 2020
[Music]
but this one comes with a message
culvert is real
it affects all of us a life or death
message for mike brazeau
whose wife michelle just came off a
ventilator struggling with colbit
the alberta man wasn't up to doing an
interview still waiting to speak to her
but his message could use some
amplifying are you concerned about the
virus at all
no why not because it's not real
this weekend hundreds of people
protested new covet 19 restrictions in
alberta
a handful sporting jackets of the far
right extremist group proud boys
my children miss school they miss their
friends
but they can't breathe in masks and
i'm their advocate the justice center
for constitutional freedoms has launched
a new court challenge against the
province
and the lockdown measures are illegal
under the charter premier jason kenney
called the gathering
irresponsible tweeting while there are
charter protected rights in canada
we also have responsibilities as
citizens certainly
there's lots of metrics in alberta that
are headed in the wrong direction
alberta has extremely high case numbers
with the test positivity rate topping 10
percent friday
icu's over capacity and a call this week
to conserve oxygen
in hospitals due to the expected
increase in demand
i just don't think we have more time to
wait i think this week we absolutely
need strong restrictive measures
implemented imposing mandatory
restrictions on social gatherings in
people's homes where we really
saw that as the the main concern on the
west block with mercedes stevenson
alberta's health minister pushed back
against criticisms his province isn't
doing enough
we want to see our our rate come down
below one
we haven't seen that yet at this time
and so it is the case that we might be
imposing further measures
we're going to be reviewing that data
with our public health officials though
before december 15th the r rate refers
to the average number of people infected
by each case
experts across the country want it to be
lower than one
alberta's government promised to make
the current rate public by now but
hasn't done that since november 22nd
as for any future measures the premier
said they would likely be targeted at
calgary and edmonton
and not rural communities with fewer
cases
abigail beeman global news ottawa
after shattering the record for cases in
a single day on saturday today quebec
reached
another stark statistic the province
surpassed 150
thousand kova 19 cases since the
pandemic began
that's the most in canada and as mike
armstrong reports
there are predictions the crisis will
just get worse
they're calling it a last resort the
regional health board for montreal's
west island
is telling west islanders to stay away
from their local hospital
the board says the lake shore general
has had covet 19 outbreaks in several
departments
and its emergency ward is considerably
over capacity
at 132 percent now this is exactly what
health officials are trying to avoid
overwhelming the system basically every
measure or restriction put on the public
has been about protecting the ability of
hospitals to treat
patients things are not getting better
this epidemiologist says a tighter
lockdown may be needed already the virus
is spreading too quickly
the focus shouldn't just be the current
situation he says
but what's coming we are just getting
into the winter
the worst months of the pandemic
may actually be in front of us the date
that has the premier nervous is december
25th
christmas what happens if families get
together for the holidays frasoligo had
said he'd decide
whether to allow gatherings for
christmas december 11th
he didn't wait that long this was
thursday
i'm announcing that gatherings
in red zones won't be allowed for
christmas
now the province is also worried about
people shopping for the holidays
it brought in new rules as of friday
across the board
stores and shopping centers are only
allowed 20 percent
capacity everyone has to do exactly the
same
and this is mandatory businesses caught
not following the rules can face fines
or even be closed
the rules also apply to shoppers patrons
can be fined
police in laval north of montreal posted
this photo this weekend
to say they're out and watching
mike armstrong global news montreal
for the first time ontario is reporting
more than 1900 new cases of coven 19.
it's the second straight day of
record-breaking numbers
much of the greater toronto area is
locked down but one region is still open
and people are heading to malls there to
do their christmas shopping
as morgan campbell reports the medical
community worries that may push the
caseload
and stress the health care system even
more than it already has
shoppers turned out in droves sunday
lining up to enter
von mills outlet mall just north of
toronto i tried to go in
bath and body works and the line
was ridiculous wrap around the
food court twice the mall has been crazy
i'm surprised at how busy it is actually
but we just quickly came in for a few
offers and now we're heading home
home is exactly where medical
professionals say
people in most parts of the greater
toronto area
should be as the province continues to
see a spike
in new coveted 19 cases ontario
continues to smash
records for the second day in a row
reporting
nearly 2 000 new cases
of the novel coronavirus and while those
statistics
are concerning experts say lockdown
measures although controversial
seem to be working i think it would
really be
a tragedy it would be you know with
projections where
20 000 people a day i mean there's no
way we cope with that
starting monday in all toronto public
and catholic schools
a new stricter screening process will be
in place
it involves a number of measures
including if a student has even
one symptom of the virus everyone in
their household
must stay home for 10 days this follows
numerous outbreak investigations in two
of the country's
largest school boards it is a move this
mother
can get behind it makes sense so i
support that aspect of it
it's just going to be probably a lot
more kids not being in class
medical experts say it is just one more
layer of protection for those within
a school community talking about any new
onset symptoms and parents know
when when a kid's sick even if it's
minor i think it's the right thing to do
and while the province deals with the
largest single day increase to date
residents are trying to cling to some
kind of normalcy
a holiday season that somewhat resembles
years past
if you have to take the extra
precautions to stand in line then
so be it morgan campbell global news
today a bit of good news out of new
brunswick the province is moving
fredericton and moncton back into the
less restrictive yellow phase at
midnight
the chief medical officer credits
residents following the rules
and bringing numbers down in the u.s the
white house says the worst days of the
copen 19 pandemic are still ahead
a special committee is set to approve a
vaccine on thursday
first responders and residents in
long-term care homes are the first
priority
the general public could start getting
the shots in the spring
as jennifer johnson reports the vaccine
can't come soon enough to stop the
latest surge in deaths
and hospitalizations federal health
officials are calling on americans to
stay vigilant
as they race to roll out a covet 19
vaccine
we're going to focus on those most
vulnerable and those most on the front
lines of treating people with covid with
the initial 40 million doses in the next
month
a food and drug administration advisory
group will vote thursday
to give emergency use authorization for
the pfizer vaccine
if approved millions of doses will then
be fast tracked to each state
within i would say 36 hours from
approval potentially the first
immunization could be taking place
officials say general population
vaccinations could begin by april
in a race to stop a virus that's killing
about 2 000 americans a day
the vaccine's critical but it's not
going to save us from this current surge
only we can save us from this current
surge dr burks and others are frustrated
so many americans still refuse to
physically distance
or wear masks and calling out state
leaders for not doing enough
we have governors and mayors who have
cases equivalent to what they had in the
summertime
yet aren't putting in the same policies
and mitigations that they put in the
summer
some governors are making unpopular
decisions starting sunday night in
california
a stricter more widespread stay-at-home
order goes into effect
as icu beds become scarce people's jobs
their businesses their livelihoods are
at stake
this is going to be painful i think this
is going to be the nail and the coffin
of a lot of restaurants here in san
francisco
trump administration doctors plan to
brief the biden transition team this
week
after the president-elect questioned
whether there was a plan to properly
administer the vaccines
since some require ultra cold
refrigeration
jennifer johnson global news washington
masks and social distancing were not
required for president donald trump's
tightly packed rally in georgia
we're fighting very hard for this state
when you look at all of the corruption
and all of the problems having to do
with this election
trump touted more baseless claims about
election fraud
he was in georgia campaigning for two
republican candidates
running in a senate runoff democrat joe
biden won georgia in the presidential
election but the two state senate races
did not result in a winner
a special election will be held next
month and it is key for both parties
it will decide who controls the senate
after biden's inauguration
we have a big senatorial race going on
in georgia
and we are watching democrats very very
closely and remember this
we had this massive race all over the
country so they could cheat
in georgia and people aren't really
watching it like they should
in another development the president
says his personal lawyer rudy giuliani
has
tested positive for coven 19. he's the
latest in trump's inner circle who have
contracted the novel coronavirus
it's not clear if giuliani is
experiencing any symptoms but
at 76 years old he is considered
high risk a new study may have found the
cause of the mysterious havana syndrome
the report by the u.s national academy
of sciences says
directed pulsed radio frequency energy
appears to be the most plausible
explanation
in 2016 dozens of american and canadian
embassy staff in cuba
started getting sick their symptoms
included hearing loss
nausea headaches and dizziness many
still continue to experience those
symptoms
or have other health problems copen19
restrictions have limited the annual
memorial for the women killed
in the montreal massacre a small crowd
gathered in person to lay flowers at a
park honoring those who lost their lives
in the mass shooting
at a cold poly technique 31 years ago
today
other commemorations are happening
virtually the anti-feminist attack on
the engineering school was one of the
deadliest mass shootings in canadian
history
on december 6 1989 a gunman stormed into
a classroom ordering
all of the men out then opening fire on
the women remaining inside
he then roamed the school shooting and
stabbing more women
before killing himself in just 20
minutes
he killed 14 women and injured more than
a dozen
coming up why recreational property is
so popular
during a pandemic and the six-year
mission to gather
asteroid dust why it's so important
cofit 19 has caused a big slowdown in
the global economy but there's one
sector that has surprised many
and come out strong canadian real estate
some analysts say the pandemic is
pushing sales and as ross lord reports
the prices are soaring beyond the big
cities
at a time when the only constant is
change there's a big shift in the
canadian real estate
industry real estate is one of those
sectors that has actually
seen what i call a covid catalyst
maybe the three p's of the pandemic
puppies peloton and property home prices
are up about 10 percent
this year and your report says cottage
country known as the recreational market
is especially hot by the end of
september year-over-year home prices and
recreational property increased by
eleven point five percent
to an average of four hundred fifty
thousand dollars
waterfront housing is even hotter with
prices increasing by thirteen point
five percent to an average of almost a
half million dollars
you see people saying you know
my job can be done from anywhere i'm
making that decision
so potentially i'm going to relocate my
family to a place where the cost of
living is less
and the quality of life
might be better for me questions about a
home's internet speed are now a priority
royal lepage reports more than half of
new buyers
are looking at recreational properties
as full-time homes exactly the thinking
with this cottage in falcon lake
manitoba
near the ontario border we actually were
looking at moving
our home in the city and when this thing
came up
we just we were like now we'll buy this
instead
some of the increase is pet up demand
from the spring lockdown that paralyzed
real estate
in atlanta canada long considered the
best real estate deal in the country
there are far more buyers than sellers
as a result
the cost is skyrocketing even i was
shocked at the price it was you know
almost two hundred thousand dollars over
the asking price
royal lepage doesn't see the trend
letting up it's forecasting demand
and prices for recreational properties
will keep increasing in the new year
ross lord global news
still ahead why are coping 19 deaths so
low
on the vulnerable continent
and we can see a lot of stairs
japan space agency has a lot to
celebrate after ending a six-year
mission
the unmanned hayabusa 2 spacecraft
passed by earth today
dropping off a capsule of samples from
an asteroid
that will help study the solar system's
origins the capsule landed in australia
the probe is now headed toward another
asteroid that could take
another 10 years to reach
more than 1.5 million people around the
world have died from covet 19
since the pandemic began about half of
those have been in north america and
europe
so far only about 53 000 deaths have
been recorded in africa
researchers are still unsure why the
number is so low
but it could be a vast underestimation
of the true figure
and as the world starts distributing
vaccines countries across
africa are asking not to be left behind
redmond shannon reports
for people fleeing islamist violence in
burkina faso
social distancing is far down the list
of priorities
this aid worker says you can't avoid
contact when helping people
and for many of the one billion people
across the continent of africa
close contact is a part of life so why
does the covert death rate appear to be
so low
the two most important factors are age
and the presence of comorbidities
and we found ourselves in a continent
where these two
are lower compared to what you find
elsewhere
more developed nations like south africa
and morocco
record more cases and deaths suggesting
that a lack of testing and monitoring
could also explain what's going on a new
study of data in sudan's capital
khartoum
says deaths could be more than 20 times
higher than official figures
the case facility ratio as it's spaced
across
ages appears to be similar to capitality
ratios we're seeing from
other hospitals in the world it
estimates more than 35
of residents have already been infected
the world health organization says covet
19 may impede the treatment of
other diseases like malaria and hiv aids
potentially adding more indirect deaths
than those coming directly from the
pandemic
partly lockdowns people
couldn't move another reason
is the issue of accessibility because of
logistics
a closure of borders some countries are
using the experience of epidemics like
ebola to educate
to monitor and soon to vaccinate the
next thing is actually getting the
vaccine distributed to your contrary
and then thirdly it's setting up the
logistics and distribution channels
and storage and other things within your
own country so it's a huge undertaking
canada is among dozens of richer nations
that have committed to fund
kovacs a program to quickly distribute
affordable covert 19 vaccines in
developing countries
the united states and russia are not
part of that plan
redmond shannon global news london
the oxford team behind the astrozenica
vaccine is making progress on a
potential
malaria vaccine the vaccine is about to
enter the final stage of human trials
it'll be tested on 4 800 children in
africa next year if all goes well
the vaccine could be in use by 2024.
malaria is a mosquito-borne infectious
disease it's treatable with drugs
but a vaccine could prevent up to half a
million malaria-related deaths
each year up next the canadian
friends star who's using fashion to
fight the pandemic
chandler can't dance but he can make a
t-shirt canadian actor matthew perry has
launched a limited edition clothing
collection inspired by friends the hit
tv show he's known for
all the proceeds will go to the world
health organization's coven 19
relief efforts in response the who
tweeted
we are more than friends we are family
we told you about the vancouver canucks
parting ways with their longtime anthem
singer over his involvement in a rally
against kova 19 restrictions
well that story garnered lots of
attention on social media but there was
one
unintended consequence the team's owner
revealed he was firing mark donnelly in
a tweet friday night ahead of the
singer's appearance at the protest in
downtown vancouver
yesterday twitter was inundated with
reaction
except it was a different mark donnelly
bearing the brunt of it all
a british sports writer who says he has
received well over
a thousand misdirected tweets
it's been uh yeah a little bit strange
uh certainly at first
thinking what have i done here why am i
getting all these messages and then
realizing
obviously they weren't uh weren't
intended for me but there's been a lot
of really nice messages as well of
obviously
people from vancouver being really
apologetic that i've kind of been caught
up in all of this and they're
being very very nice and very very kind
about it all which is really really nice
to see
he also cleared up any confusion about
the differences between him
and the other mark donnelly saying on
twitter yes i wear a mask and advocate
everyone doing so no i can't sing no i
can't skate
yes i promise i'm not actually a
six-year-old anthem singer
masquerading as a journalist and that is
global national for this sunday i'm
robin gill tonight your canada is bird
river manitoba
thank you for watching donna friesen
will be back tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
you